so given everything Tara went through in
Scream five we don't learn a whole lot
about who she is what she's into things
like that so what particular new layer
of hers were you most looking forward to
finally getting to show to audiences and
scream sex just any bit of Personality
something that wasn't on the verge of
death and crying in tears the whole time
I think it was really interesting to
kind of almost have that freedom in the
last one because
yes added layer of trauma always loved
that when I you know I'm working with a
character but then also I get to kind of
play off of Melissa's already so
beautifully crafted Sam and I think that
my kind of goal with this one was just
kind of make them
uh enough just kind of Polar Opposites
in a sense but still some sort of sister
Dynamic I just wanted to make her uh
feminine and um or overly feminine and
very social and in light and and just um
very uh not concerned with what has
happened to them and just kind of push
it to the side and like Sam who's kind
of all consumed by it so we did know
that she was very into a24 horror movies
in that is she a big fan of X now
uh I feel like she may be off of horror
films actually I feel like she's just
anything horror related is out the
window she might be watching musicals or
something
fair enough
um Melissa for you so I was reading the
Press notes and there's a quote from you
that says uh some people are really into
Sam and some people are unsure so how
did the response to the character in
Scream 5 influence your approach to the
role in Scream Six and also what would
you tease for people out there who are
still unsure of Sam going into this new
movie listen there's nothing I can do
about people's opinions and everyone has
a right to have their own opinions so
I'm just gonna keep doing my job that I
love to do and those that are in for it
cool and those that don't I I mean I'm
sorry but um I I feel like
um
it's you know it's whatever it's it's uh
it is what it is coming into a franchise
that's so beloved and and so and has
such a history
um and like the the fans have such
ownership of the material and the
characters and all of that and I'm just
happy to get to share a little bit more
of Sam in this next installment and and
keep playing with people that I love and
and keep this story going